did you guys see that one senator from
uh west virginia it's barrasso what's
his name barrasso john barrasso
uh i want to say wyoming wyoming yeah
he's from wyoming so he went out there
he went out there and he said the whole
thing about well you know who's seen
this
2500 page uh uh what do you call it bill
who's taking a look at this etc how many
people you think have read it and they
expect us to yeah john barrasso yeah and
so but here's the thing what we did i
said okay i want to know the bill i want
to read the bill i want to go through it
kai how many hours did we spend looking
at the bill and did you find anything
could we find the bill anywhere
at least a good hour and we couldn't
find it anywhere we were looking at
literally the first two three pages on
google trying to find
congress's website the government's
website everywhere it's probably on the
dark web in china so there is some
websites that are talking about it let's
go to page eight guys there's some
websites that are talking about it and
some people uh who are sharing some
points on what's in it this is one of
them
and i'm going to cover kai if you want
to pull up the article that even the
audience can see
uh this is from what this is fox
business go to page eight if you can
find that article what's in it one of
the ones that's in it is really
concerning on page 168 of the bill 168
of the bill which we don't have access
to the bill but 168 of the bill
it covers a fine
i don't know if you guys have seen that
seven hundred thousand dollar fine but
let me get right into it so
three and a half trillion dollar
spending package includes big money for
free uh tree equity bias training and
more apparently one of the things on
page 168 of the bill is if an employer
if an employer has an employee that's
unvaccinated it's seven hundred thousand
dollar fine per employee that's
unvaccinated let me say that one more
time okay if an employee is unvaccinated
it's seven hundred thousand dollar fine
per employee that's unvaccinated how
many companies can handle that i don't
know how many companies can handle that
and this is all over the place about the
seven hundred thousand dollars so you
got nearly 79 79 billion dollar bill for
the irs
uh uh folks out of the three and a half
trillion dollars 80 billion of it is
purely for irs 12 billion for electric
cars 3 billion for tree equity 1 billion
to turn government into facilities into
high performance green buildings and new
funding for gender
identity issues and bias training
amongst the most contentious provisions
the bill gives a substantial funding
boost to internal revenue service that
stands again 80 billion over the next 10
years so out of the three and a half
trillion dollars the biggest money is
going to the irs that makes a lot of
sense i mean folks we should vote for
this this is absolutely fascinating to
have more irs
agents going and trying to find that 600
that they're talking about the money
would help the irs strengthen tax
enforcement activities what a friendly
thing to say the irs strengthened tax
enforcement activity something we all
love and support expand audits and
modernize its technology an additional
410 million dollars would go to irs
oversight democrats are also putting
equity at the center of the bill the
agriculture committee has uh earmarked
three billion dollars for a tree
planting program with a priority for
projects that increase
uh tree equity the legislation dishes
that another four billion dollars for
neighborhood access and equity grants
meanwhile it's electric vehicle charging
equity program comes with a one billion
dollar price tag senator joe manchin
uh from west virginia kristin
uh cinnamon from
arizona both democrats have been the
most vocal in their opposition and even
they have been negotiating separately
mentioned to a political on thursday
what's the need there is no timeline i
want to understand it while
representative for cinema told the same
outlet kristen recognizes there's a
timeline there's got to be a process but
said she was consulting with colleagues
about the key provisions the cost of the
bill the cost of the bill originally was
three and a half trillion dollars but
the non-partisan committee of the
responsible federal budget wrote in july
that the true cost would be uh end up
being around five and a half trillion
dollars the new york times respond on
monday morning that the current bill is
likely to cost well over three and a
half trillion dollars again that's not
new york post that's new york time
saying it's gonna be well over three and
a half trillion dollars and last but not
least figuring out the true cost could
take time the bill formerly known as the
buildback better act weighs in 2
465 pages 444 000 words that is uh
three times the size of atlas shrugs a
book which is a long book and each page
is 1.4 billion dollars okay is what
you're looking at so
that's what that's why manchin says we
need to take a pause we need to pause
tom brought up a great point i mean
think about the worst legislation that's
ever been done in this country
it's it's legislation that wasn't read
and that's i mean right tom remember the
aca yeah of course
kai see if you can find the clip from
nancy pelosi when she got cornered said
what's in it we'll find out what's in it
when it's passed
yeah he says have you read it why is
that even acceptable like why whether
you're republican or democrat why is it
even acceptable
let's just look at this when we're
already past the bill why does that make
any sense
they need to change the title by the way
yesterday that it's a slush fund they're
passing dollars not bills they're
passing dollars how much of this three
and a half trillion dollars is going to
the people
now okay how many of those are not
that's not you're talking about child
tax credit
these are two different things i'm
talking about that's a major even that
is controversial that's that's not
that's not okay so what percentage three
half trillion dollars gonna go to the
people
i don't know but here can i just give
you what the top five things like i know
we talked about irs 80 billion 80
billion 12 billion for electric cars
three billion for tree equity whatever
that is one billion for gender okay
those are minor
you know lines on the budget the big
five apparently of this three and a half
trillion dollar
spending plan is climate change you
talked about the child tax credit which
apparently is a big deal if you got kids
uh universal pre-k right now that
doesn't exist in the country
fade family uh paid family leave and
expanding medicare to cover i guess
dental vision and other things so those
are the big five things within this bill
now within the each of those categories
i'm sure there's like you said slush
funds and why won't they show what what
the categories are but those are the big
five caps and it's spread out over ten
years i mean please so here's the
challenge here's the challenge here
here's the disaster right question yeah
here's a challenge i got my challenge is
the following
if i'm correct me on this one but i read
in like a handful of different places
this is the only one that a bill like
this passed and there's no hearing so
they're not having a hearing meaning
they're not willing to have a hearing to
answer what's in it so you know how
typically there's a hearing then they'll
say why this and why that and why this
they don't want to do hearing so there
is nobody from the opposing side or
mansion or kristen they cannot ask why
are we spending this much money on this
that's a problem because that's why
manchin has said what happened kai kai
found something you found a bill i think
tyler found the bill can you go to page
168 of the bill
go to page 168 i want to i want to
verify this because this doesn't make
any sense to me so
uh papa papa in addition to amounts of
otherwise available any of the money in
the treasury in other words appropriate
there's only 300 million there it is
line 15 line 15. okay uh uh occupancy
stateful health act of 1970 occupation
so
i'm trying to see where it says the
vaccine the employment commission
uh uh so you got occupational safety and
health act of 1970 section 17 of the
occupational safety health yeah because
osha is going to be their cop in
subsection 1a
a striking 70 dollars and inserting
seven hundred dollars there's the
increase fine now we gotta find just by
striking oh so they're increasing it
from seventy to seven hundred by
striking fifty and inserting fifty thou
ten times the fine just ten times oh my
gosh by by striking seven thousand
inserting seventy thousand but guys this
is
this is how bad legislation is passed
because they're desperately looking
and who wants to bring back
the salt deduction
you know for for right property taxes
state
the democrats they actually want to put
there are some democrats who are
opposing this bill if it does not get
rid of the cap on property taxes and
this is this is biden remember being
told i'm sorry you can't can you email
me you can't do that with an executive
order you can't force vaccination of the
executive order well who could we do it
oh we'll get osha
we'll get one of our many cops in
government and we'll throw it at osha so
that osha goes out and does it yeah
but this three and a half
trillion dollar spending bill isn't the
only thing on the agenda right now you
were talking about the big four things
that are on the plate right now
you want to touch on that so
republicans a few days ago
they said to chuck schumer who's the
senate majority leader right now
schumer kept trying to put the debt
ceiling inside of the continuing
resolution to keep the government open
after
midnight tonight because midnight
tonight is when the u united states
fiscal year ends
yeah and that's something i learned by
the way that the fiscal year of the
united states ends september the 13th
september 30th not not at the end of the
year nope it's not accounting for school
year it's fiscal year we learned
something everybody go ahead so but
after midnight
and the the republicans are going to
vote for what's taken to the floor
but they were they said you got to take
the debt ceiling out of it or you're not
going to get the votes so schumer had to
pull back and they've removed the debt
ceiling which takes us back to patrick's
birthday october the 18th x date that's
the date at which
i mean if your family's got uh you know
plans to go to washington dc you might
want to take the smithsonian off the
list that's when federal agencies start
to close when did the government shut
down external pictures well yes and
that's nft when when's the last time the
government shutdown
oh gosh was it 2000
was it 18. wasn't it 18.
the famous trump pelosi
schumer meeting
2019 is when the debt ceiling was
suspended july 31 2019 it was suspended
for two years meaning by july the 31st
2021 they would have to raise it
but the reason that it was and there was
no controversy
there was
pelosi and trumpeter thought that they
were cousins kissing cousins at that it
was so
non-controversial because it lifted the
cap past the election
so whoever got elected in 2020 would
have unlimited spending power
until july the 31st yes and that was
that that was the reason that there was
so
little controversy i think when clinton
was in office i seem to remember
um federal workers no there was
something like two or three years ago
where the government shut down for like
two months and you had federal workers
going crazy they couldn't pay their rent
it's but this was recent yes this this
does happen from time to time the reason
it's different right now
is because the republicans are
this is a quote from mitch mcconnell
they asked a reporter asked mr mcconnell
what did you learn from 2011 which is
when the u.s sovereign debt rating was
downgraded he said what i learned was
even though i had pressure from within
my party so even though he he was
getting pressure from within the gop
to to kill
who'd been kidnapped and that was the
analogy that he used this is the tea
party doing their thing at that point he
said that the lesson that he learned is
you don't do it you collect the ransom
that means that you actually force
negotiations to address entitlement
spending so that the debt of the united
states quits running up at a crazy rate
and that was why s p downgraded the
country they were like what are they
doing why are they doing this they're
still not addressing long-term
entitlement spending that the country
cannot afford
and as long as you continue to ignore
those elephants in the room and in this
three and a half trillion thing it wants
to go the opposite direction it wants to
create social spending programs that
never go away you never create a
government program that gets cancelled
it doesn't work that way now they use
the term entitlement like crazy
entitlement talent what's the biggest
entitlement medicare medicaid social
security those three and then welfare
excuse me funded entitlements unfunded
entitled unfunded that's exactly right
that's exactly liabilities so they're
talking about what's there
unfortunately in 2013
for
then federal reserve chair ben bernanke
they had a blueprint drawn up
well gee the federal reserve owns a
whole bunch of u.s treasuries because
it's been buying up u.s treasuries for
all this time now it owns 25 percent of
u.s treasuries there is a blueprint to
strategically default only on debt on
the fed's balance sheet and it was
written up for ben bernanke in 2013. i
can guarantee you that the fed hates the
fact that this document is actually in
the public purview but there is a way
and mitch mcconnell knows it there is a
way for the united states to
strategically default on the on the
paper owned on the bonds owned by the
federal reserve and man fitch and
moody's would be right behind them
downgrading just like s p did if they
did it it's the nuclear option but it's
a nuclear option that mitch mcconnell is
very aware of
you think you'll use it you think you'll
use that card i mean look the stock the
stock market's up the economy has not
fallen out of bed inflation's a real
problem
and right now
as long as the economy doesn't fall out
of bed which threatens the midterms for
all incumbents across both parties i
think mitch is going to take this thing
to the wire
so if he takes it to the wire let's just
say he takes it to the wire and he uses
that card what happens to the economy
how ugly could it be it could be very
ugly ugly is 20 or 10 percent it could
be it the united
the united states defaulting on its debt
i mean just say that repeat that the
united states of america the risk-free
asset for the free world
not
not paying its obligations not making an
interest payment you hear about that you
know with third world countries
argentina how many times has argentina
defaulted on its debt
count the way greece
those are the kind of countries that
that you you you have conversations
about debt defaulting so not the united
states across the aisle are the the
mcconnells of the world in the pelosi's
world the schumers of the world
privately saying like look
this isn't a good look for america to
default on our debt we got to figure
this thing out are they having the
public they're going to talk they're
going to say one thing
this is the thing and this is the reason
that mitch mcconnell gave chuck schumer
the bird a few days ago and this is what
mitch mcconnell has been insisting if
you want to raise the debt ceiling using
reconciliation straight on party lines
go for it they won't even need
advertising agencies for the for for the
midterms if the republicans manage to
flawlessly easily elegantly
put seven trillion dollars on the
democrats see that's what schumer's not
going to do that's what schumer and and
schumer won't do it that's why they will
not raise the debt ceiling using using
reconciliation because they they'll all
get voted out of office and he tried to
slip it in there and mcconnell said
take that cheese off my hamburger you
don't remind the burger but take that
cheese and that's why that's why schumer
keeps saying it's you know this is
disastrous we cannot default on the debt
and mcconnell keeps saying then raise
the debt limit along party lines own it
it seems like a simple provision chuck
and there's we're all sitting here in
the chamber why don't you walk to the
front make a few preamble statements and
put it on the floor baby i mean in in
2019 we raised the we we raised the debt
limit by like 2 trillion
this is like 3x that
and don't get me wrong this is debt that
was incurred in during the trump
administration this is the cares act
this is the trillions and trillions and
trillions of dollars that were
legislated it is money that has been
spent
um but the republicans are saying to the
democrats own it so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]